le député iconoclaste on va dire le
député qui chante le député qui marche
on va y revenir parce que vous avez
sorti ce livre en janvier à la rencontre
des français et vous êtes député qui a
fait acte de candidature à la
candidature et qui gênent peut-être
aussi qui a fait acte de candidature à
la candidature pour mener la liste modem
udi ump aux prochaines régionales
c'était lors d'une réunion voilà un
terme à ces différents partis pour
quelles raisons vous décidez de sade
vous présenter pour mener cette liste
alors bonjour à dos avant le jour à
internet j'ai fait acte de candidature
parce que alain juppé réunis nous étions
très nombreux à penser que sortir des
fêtes de la nouvelle tunisie de
personnes septième opus il y avait la
plupart des maires de grandes villes y
avait beaucoup de présidents de conseils
généraux
il y avait des conseillers régionaux
voilà sept grandes régions qui
comprendra aussi le limousin élevé haute
charente
les trois anciennes amies et faisons un
tour de table où tout le monde s'est ému
à la fois de la région qu'elle n'était
pas bien qu'elle n'avait pas etc
j'étais le dernier à parler puisque la
juppé avait lancé un tour de table et je
me trouvais à l'extrémité de l'autre
tant que de monde ce temple un hôtel de
la région notamment s'étant plaints que
la les y avoir des actions de régions
très éloignées du centre de gravité qui
pourrait être lourde autres et puis
après avoir dit que là vous savez quand
même même aux dernières européennes a
quitté une sonnerie la saison pour le
parti socialiste lui place avec tous ses
alliés sur l'ensemble du bloc centre
droit
après avoir dit que c'était très
difficile à accepter
bon moi j'ai découpé la biologiste la
région existe les élections sont prévues
ils sont prévus il s'agit de savoir si
nous voulons que ce soit là où c'est
qu'il a choisi la présence de
l'aquitaine aussi nous voulons que ce
soit quelqu'un d'autre car nous faisons
aux problèmes de centralisation
on peut tourner éventuellement en
prenant ce candidat suffisamment
excentré d'accord pour que dès à présent
à l'esprit en permanence cette liste-là
on veut prendre pour contourner les
problèmes de front national parce qu'il
a mis sur la table aussi quelqu'un de
suffisamment singulier way pour que les
partis eux mêmes soient surpris et que
d'accord donc vous avez surpris tout le
monde y compris à la jb vous avez dit à
cette personne c'est moi je vais me
neigeux pourrait mener cette liste si
vous ne voulez rien et achèterait de
mener cette liste une condition c'est
comme se perdre un jour il est déjà en
campagne
je n'ai envie de participer aucune
pourtant je la salle vous imaginez bien
qui aura comme une candidature ump face
à vous on peut imaginer une compétition
quand vous vous le voyez c'est une
candidature à la candidature pour
l'instant reçu de la nourriture
moi j'ai clairement dit ce qu'il en
était en moto n'est pas ce que ça suffit
de faire on connaît c'est sûr mais on
n'arrête pas de se placer alors que cela
donne trois semaines
dimanche après dimanche de déplorer la
montée inexorable du front national
et de déplorer que
cinquante pour ça donc aux citoyens ne
voient déjà plus aux urnes alors soit on
continue soit alors on est vous presque
fait quelque chose
vous êtes un candidat qui est plus à
même de parler à cet électorat c'est ça
je ne parle pas car cet électorat
je crois que nos compatriotes je vais
bien mais riffier durant le tour de
france aspire à retrouver des hommes
politiques qui d'abord les écoutes
oublier le respect de les écouter le
temps qu'il faut et puis ensuite de les
remettre en position de citoyenneté pour
construire ensemble et je n'ai projet le
plus large possible pour qu'il ait un
véritable socle et je crois
effectivement être je ne suis pas le
seul mais être de ces hommes personnes
expérience à la capacité d'avoir à
donner une identité à cet avis parce que
pour commencer elle n'a pas justement
juin salle vous parlez du front national
l'union de la droite et du centre existe
déjà au moins pour les élections
départementales en particulier en
pyrénées atlantiques chez vous donc été
rejoints une question de nos internautes
est ce que cette union de la droite et
du centre c'est une bonne stratégie pour
contrer le front national qui est en
tête des intentions de vote aujourd'hui
alors d'avoir su mettre les choses au
point
très fin avec nos internautes avec nos
lecteurs
elle existe momentanément
bien sûr il n'est pas dit qu'elle existe
7 ans parce que je savais c'est
tellement fou ça vient et ponctuellement
ce jour là le jour où j'ai parlé elle
exister puisque tout le monde était
autour de la table donc c'est à eux que
je me suis adressé alors est ce que
c'est une bonne réponse en tout cas
c'est pas une mauvaise réponse parce que
chaque fois comme se réunit on est quand
même plus fort pour faire interne les
partis démocratiques l'homme a reconnu
le front national est aussi d'ailleurs
mais les partis qui sont plutôt amené à
conduire les affaires et les pays et les
régions
départ de raphaël les pays de brûler les
partis de pouvoir qui ne manie pas en
permanence le rejet de lente mais vous
savez ce qu'on dit un peu à l'ump
finalement voilà est-ce que vous avez
cette légitimité vous êtes peut-être pas
le meilleur gestionnaire qui et vous
est-ce que vous avez voilà la carrure
pour mener cette grande région
il y aura des candidats potentiels
peut-être on parle de dominique
bussereau etc
voilà c'est une c'est une question c'est
une question à l'ump est ce que vous
qu'est ce que vous dites et ça est ce
que vous dites penser que oui c'est pas
parce que vous avez vous n'avez pas
gérer une très grande collectivité qu'on
n'est pas capable de le faire
ce qui concerne le site yves et qui font
partie de débat démocratique et que
j'évolue posée mais pas dans cet état je
voulais poser tous d'accord et la
réponse a été quoi qu'elle commence à la
mère suez
c'est à dire vous ai dit quoi regardez
pas ce jour là tous dessus et landais
non non vous avez adressé des raisons
vous avez passé des coups de fil après
je suis jeune et je sais mais de quels
droits des créateurs et tant que je suis
mauvais gestionnaires je ne sais pas
rires je suis depuis 38 ans j'ai géré ma
propre affaire pendant trente-cinq avait
quand même dix salariés ils ont tâtonné
prétendant qu'ils peuvent en dire autant
sans l'ombre d'un problème dans cet
ingénieur à simple j'ai géré ma commune
j'ai été président du parc national
je gère le site us et patrimoniale du
haut béarn et je suis président d'une
des rares structures mondiales qui
existe là après c'est pas de mon fait si
jusqu'à maintenant on a plus souvent
demandé d'accompagner avec brio ce qui
présente ce qui se présentait en tête de
liste ou en tête de série dans toutes
les élections et si je n'ai pas eu la
chance de pouvoir gérer un grand
exécutif justement faire on n'arrive pas
je crois mon âge sans avoir une petite
idée de la manière de gérer et
d'ailleurs ce propos là j'ai déjà engagé
m du travail parce qu'il va y avoir un
sacré talent de gestion pour le coup
parce que qu'est-ce qu'on fait des deux
hôtels de région qu'on ferme ou qui vont
passer 15
au deuxième plan il faut qu'en dire les
choses que lassant et comment on va
gérer ça c'est beaucoup plus préoccupant
est peut être douloureux le moment venu
de tous les personnels qui risque est en
doublons ou en triplette
ça c'est une suggestion de m déjà
réfléchi à ce point j'ai pas réfléchi
totalement je ne pose la question parce
que ce dont vous parlez de réunions de
la gpa remonte à peine sommes donc je
quand même pas eu le temps j'ai pas les
vôtres de satillieu pour aller aussi
vite mais c'est pour vous montrer que je
prend cette affaire très au sérieux et
que cette en pleine responsabilité parce
qu'il ya la gestion que nous savons
faire nous les politiques avec nos
petits attaché-case tout semblait le
chiffre tous différents auxquels nos
compatriotes
elle n'a rien il ya aussi le véritable
vision de la gestion quelle région pour
quoi faire
quels projets et avec 10 jeux toutes les
manières jean lassalle ça revient à
votre à votre livre à la rencontre des
français dans ce livre vous racontez une
scène où pendant la campagne législative
où je crois vous êtes au pays basque
comme vous demande de bien vous dit
pourquoi on voterait pour vous et là
vous raconter une scène assez étonnante
vous faites le poirier vous raconter
tout von teese était de parterres vous
le verrez ça fait partie de votre
personnalité on vous connaît pour vous
face et si vous avez chanté l'assemblée
etc
mais pourquoi avez vous éprouvé le
besoin de faire le poirier devant ses
électeurs potentiels qu'est ce que vous
avez voulu leur montrer ça fait partie
de votre personnage et à un moment où
vous briguez pourquoi pas une tête de
liste pour les régionales
qu'est ce que c'est un peu qui jean
lassalle pour quoi il est capable d'une
future président d'une grande région
pour faire le poirier comme ça président
de région doit pouvoir faire le maximum
de choses surtout en des temps si
difficiles que ceux qui nous attendent
et au niveau national et au niveau des
régions d'abord il faut la faire voter
ce pas une mince affaire
alors pourquoi j'avais fait ça tout
simplement parce que j'avais été au bout
de la logique de ce que je voulais
exprimer
et il y avait dans le regard de celui
qui me posait la question il faut bien
voir où c'était c'était devenu castola
c'était la fête des 50 en asie castola
qui n'apprécie pas tellement parce que
j'avais jamais été un pur département
basque mais je n'avais pas de voyage et
les roms
il faut tout mettre
donc j'ai vu que venant de croiser une
cinquantaine de main il s'était refusé à
moi c'était pas non plus principal fait
l'invité le plus attendu et puis cet
homme regarde au fond des yeux sur
certaines cultures qui manifestera s'y
connaît en politique il me dit je nous
apprécient guère je demande une bonne
raison de me juger si vous donnez m'en
donne raison le montrer il faut vraiment
un jour pour vous j'ai quelques minutes
ne pas lui faire un voilà tout ce que
j'ai déjà dit l'idée m'a semblé qu'il
fallait que je lui montre que j'avais la
véracité a trouvé l'énergie et le
courage de faire front dans des tang
allait s'annoncer difficile et aux pays
bas
et comme on aime aussi les gens quand
certains valent h mais je crois que je
vais toucher au coeur parce qu'ils
m'avaient seul député
oui on va rester sur la région et c'est
une solveig une internaute qui vous pose
cette question elle s'étonne que cette
réforme territoriale qui va donner
naissance à ses futures grandes régions
est l'un des arguments clés a été celui
de faire des économies et pourtant elle
remarque on ne supprime pas les
différentes strates du millefeuille
territorial millefeuille administratif
pardon donc c'est la question quelle
vous pose c'est ce qu'on a encore besoin
de tout ça ces intercommunalités ce
conseil général si les grandes régions
sur tout ça je veux répondre très
sérieusement et en conscience un autre
internaute
madame je suis totalement de votre vie
c'est l'une des raisons pour lesquelles
je me suis tant battus contre la manière
dont était comme but
cette région à cette réforme parce que
d'abord
remettons nous bien je le rappelle dans
mon livre le président roland dans la
partie dû aux élèves
il n'a pas fait ce qu'a fait françois
mitterrand enfin ça mitterrand avait
abordé deux sujets terrible oui bon
boulot démagogie avec vous couvre ya eu
beaucoup de désillusions
il était porteur d'un espoir qui ne
s'est pas réalisé et c'était un peu
importe c'est du passé
mais il avait porté l'idée d'abolir la
peine de voir alors que 80 % des
français y étaient hostiles et il avait
porté l'idée d'une véritable
décentralisation il n'a pas passé l'été
qui a suivi acer photographié à changer
le femmes dans tous les magazines
c'était là il a prié aston et de
marseille
question de faire de l'île au travail
avant que le préfet ne se réveille et
que l'opposition ne se réveille et on
fait la décentralisation et ils l'ont
fait
et les français avaient voté pour cela
tandis que là qu'est ce qu'on a fait eh
bien on avait commencé par signer le
pacte européen qu'on avait juré craché
comme s'il n'y aurait jamais au nom de
la finance qui ruiné tous au prétexte
qu'elle avait ajouté la ligne sur la
première page que personne n'a jamais lu
et ensuite on s'est lancé dans le
mariage pour tous qui nous a pris quatre
mois dans lesquelles nous avons touché
les profondeurs de la honte en politique
tellement les arguments qui ont été
chargés de part et d'autre et éhontée
pour une grand pays comme le nôtre look
cité la phrase si facile à faire
moi j'ai marié de femmes l'été dernier
car l'amour et la violence aveugle bien
des choses et je n'ai eu aucun problème
dans mon village
elles ont été accueillies comme aucune
difficulté vie on a attaqué après avoir
parlé pendant quatre mois de mariage
et quand je dis aux homosexuels pour
attaquer les mariages gris nomme pour
réformer les sélections départementales
à ce moment là je n'avais pas le
sentiment que c'était d'une priorité
nous étions au mois de novembre décembre
sa main est jamais c'était une priorité
pour les électeurs qui me demandait
j'espère que vous êtes en train de
redresser le pays vous arrivez dans quel
état est l'industrie l'a vu dans quel
état l'agriculture il ya 80 pour ça des
agriculteurs qui se vend son analyse à
50 ans il n'y a pas quelqu'un pour
reprendre la suite ni le fils ni de
gouzenne et 2009
j'espère vous entendrez notre rien des
sujets comme ça et ils ne découvrent en
train de composer et de reparler à tout
prix à toute heure du jour et de la nuit
deux couples de nouveaux traditionnels
pour remplacer les cantons traditionnels
ceux qui avaient le plus besoin d'un
conseiller général et à qui on a relevé
par exemple le mien l'alsace n'a plus de
caisses régionales
c'est la raison pour laquelle je ne suis
plus représentée avec trente trois ans à
cette élection parce que je ne mets pas
supporté et c'est une erreur que nous
payons très cher
alors madame vous avez raison parce que
avant d'arriver aux régions on va voter
pour la première fois en france pour la
première fois on invite le peuple
français aller devant les urnes pour
voter pour une élection qui n'existe pas
si on avait un grand département dont on
ne connaît pas les compétences si ni les
moyens ni les moyens
et s'il s'était trouvé 60 députés pour
poser la question dans ce qui reste là
ce qui reste du conseil constitutionnel
voire du conseil d'état il ya cette
élection et était annulé et les
électeurs auraient été invités à venir
voter un peu plus tard lorsque le texte
aurait en fait été votée au parlement il
est toujours en discussion entre des
mois est-ce qu'il ya trop d âge trop
d'échelons s'il vient ensuite sommes pas
sûrs régional et maintenant nous sommes
dans les intercommunalités des
interconnectés là aussi il faut le
procès départementale tout le monde à
peu près compris de quoi il s'agissait
c'est le même nombre de conseils
généraux et 6,7 à chiffres impairs de
plus parce que c'est paris nord donc
vaut rien bon c'est pas la peine que
j'insiste
si ce n'est pour dire bravo et chapeau à
ce qu'ils font campagne parce que j'en
vois beaucoup je fais un tour de france
actuellement papier mais pour aller
soutenir des candidats d'ailleurs de sa
civilité parfois très différentes à ce
que cet album à la fin
à ceux qui m'aiment ce komajda chemin
c'est terrible quand on va sur les
marchés les parcs candidats avec des
amendes de famille ou de groupe qui fait
un long détour pour ne surtout pas les
croisés et qu'on est obligé de courir
après les lecteurs potentiels qui si par
bonheur vous tomber dessus
vous vous dites le reste est gouleyant
niveau jour je tourne j'ai trouvé un
sens est passé on avait que des
caniveaux
ça c'est un constat que vous faites dans
ce lien que cette défiance ans et la
vision que vous avez avec votre marché
enfin du peuple français c'est voilà
c'est assez pessimiste est terrible
parler de colère de frustration et
résignation
saga dream et ça continue et vous ça
veut dire ça veut dire que ça veut dire
quoi ça veut dire que le front national
va gagner alors le front national alors
survolé le front national je vous laisse
en plein terminée mais à se réaliser
ensuite il ya les intercommunalités
alors que mon concitoyen urnes proximité
facilite et occupe toi de moi aurait
plus personne pour s'occuper de moi
peut-être même vous allez faire
disparaître les nerfs c'est ceux qui en
avaient le plus confiance parce que
c'est pas du taux d its ils survivent au
mandat qu'ils sont en train de vivre
toutes les compétences voulait garder
tous les élites proximité en moi je sais
que cinq jours district est en train de
se passer
donc au lieu de simplifier on a
compliqué il va y avoir encore plus de
monde et au lieu dit françois rude à la
france est un pays exceptionnel
4le moyenne faire administrer son
immense territoire par un million de
bénévoles parce que celui-ci tôt que
s'il ya rien dire que le maire les
adjoints et en autant il y en a 1
millions derrière pour les remplacer
c'est le premier million s'avérait
inopérant parce qu'ils sont prêt à se
faire couper la tête pour un chemin de
terre où un chemin creux dans tout en
assurant que donc par 41 à 13
des jeunes gens mal payés qui se vend
dans les capitales de ces nouvelles
interrégions in ans à la tête des chefs
de départements des régions et qui
remplaceront ceux qui sont élus au
suffrage universel dans leurs multiples
et le coupent pas je ne sais combien je
suis à nous même pas d'économie
attendait ça aucun gros que l'économie
et ce qui est pire c'est que cette
réforme doit d'être en doute
mais encore une fois il faut l'annoncer
à l'occasion du canyon de campagne
présidentielle et il faut le faire dans
la foulée après avoir clairement
exprimée à la france comme voulait faire
et pas charger la juge justement des
huit jours revenir sur ce que vous dites
là dessus ça fera le lien avec le livre
vous racontez aussi une scène et ça
montre aussi un peu la fracture que l'on
vit en ce moment et qui peut expliquer
un peu ce vote front national en tout
cas ses intentions de vote vous vous
raconter quand vous marchez à aux
fonctionnaires vos appels qui
responsable des fonds européens et qui
vous dit clairement est ce que t'en a
pas marre de pleurer ses percées
pleurnichard de français la france est
devenue un pénis d'un pays de feignants
et elle a voulu opposer plusieurs
arguments
mais le discours avec ce haut
fonctionnaire et celui ci les français
sont des pleurnichards et des feignants
et vous vous dites c'est le pays qui
pleure merci de m'avoir lu que
j'apprécie beaucoup
mon poste et festive avec eux je vois
que c'est quelqu'un qui va lui a fait en
faisant corps c'est moi qui avait appelé
parce que je trouve sur le trottoir le
maire qui se présentent à voir comme un
maire d'une commune de dénis d'habitants
pas tout à fait rien et il me présenta
chef d'entreprise bien les yeux
jusqu'ici tellement il dort pas il a mis
au point un produit qui se vend très
bien surtout dans les pays de l'est mais
il a eu un contrôle fiscal et suite à ce
contrôle visuel on a remarqué qu' il
avait reçu un peu par anticipation
l'ensemble de szczesny européen qui
aurait dû lui être versé par tranches
donc dû penser que tous allaient
disparaître ça n'a pas disparu du
dossier et on a commencé par lui
demander de rembourser tout ce qu'ils
allaient reçues et ensuite avec une
amende de trois fois plus que ce qu'il
avait reçu on arrive
et de ce qu'ils pouvaient concourir dans
des appels d'offres européens donc toute
sa clientèle tombé à l'eau est différent
150 salariés et pourrait embaucher au
moins semble de plus c'est pour ça
qu'ils venaient me voir alors moi je
sais ce que je fais j'essaie de trouver
le préfet qui a faim de l'agrément il
avait changé le département je le trouve
sur le trottoir je les aurais dû si
einer reconnaît et puis je dis voilà je
veux pas parler de tas mais voilà c'est
ta femme je suis un très bien on avait
reçu une resucée ce dont sa compagne
dans le jargon de créer
je me suis dit bon compte en faire
bénéficier tout de suite plutôt que de
thésauriser ce que je ne sers à rien
j'ai versé aux deux autres à porter deux
dossiers la totalité de l'argent j'ai
dit mais vous voyez aujourd'hui il ne
peut plus concourir
on lui fait rembourser et en plus est
dans le moment terrible il va plonger
c'est un des rares centres pour la
france et que je rencontre qui a un
carnet de commandes le niveau m'écouter
quand on quitte le département il peut
plus rien voyez plutôt du côté de bercy
si vous regardez ça ou d'une structure
qui s'occupe de versement et c'est là
que je tombe sur un 6-0 fonctionnaires
avec ce qu'il me dit mais je vous aime
bien mais je comprends pas que vous
soyez à écouter tous ceux pleurnichard
je l'apprécié pas du tout parce que
qu'est ce que nous faisons tirer à ce
que c'est ça fait partie des fractures
qui minent cette société où il fait
ainsi une péripétie de français parce
que vous devez à sabra ce qui ne se
connaissent pas qui vivent les mêmes
émotions qui ont le même désir de tirer
la france du ppri et l'avocat une
entreprise et l'autre veut le punir
parce qu'il est persuadé que c'est à
cause d'eux les tricheurs comme lui que
tout c'est vrai ce que vous dites les
six mamans vous dites une banlieue la
situation est grave ça va ça va péter
c'est quelque chose qui rokicki et qui
revient ce vous exagérez pas un peu sur
l'a6 la situation vous pensez que c'est
vous pensez que vous pensez qu'on en est
là vous êtes journaliste
oui
c'est une région qui est une région qui
se portent encore le mieux dans notre
pays le constater il y en a quelques
autres et ne région qui a conservé une
identité profonde c'est grâce à qui
grâce à alain rousset je suis pas
certaine je vous laisse le soin de
trancher une question du non je ne pense
pas qu'à où c'est qu'il ya eu des succès
je pense que là où c est quand même et
l'esprit aquitain qui décrit la mairie
de vianne et 1 et l'esprit atlantique au
piano sommes si attachés l'aquitaine
quelques pages d'histoire avec le grand
palais aussi par mona ne parvienne chez
nous après avoir quitté un territoire en
perdition un peu comme se trouvait le
mieux sauf que moi je me suis attaqué
essayer de restaurer le mien laval hélas
donné que lui l'a quittée mais ça n'a
rien à voir avec la faire jean lassalle
le temps passe une telle question
oui je suis dans l'édition pour une ou
deux réponses il faut que je me ménage
oui non mais voit revenir sur le sur le
livret vous avez parlé beaucoup dans cet
entretien de la campagne présidentielle
on sait vous avez accompagné françois
bayrou et vous raconter dans ce livre
une de vos fracture avec lui lorsqu'il
annonce pendant la campagne
présidentielle qu'il votera à titre
personnel pour françois hollande et
avoue n'être pas du tout d'accord vous
raconter cette scène
alors qu'est ce qu'il reste aujourd'hui
de cette fracture est en tout cas de
cette divergence profonde qui vous a
animé tous les deux on est presque on
est trois en plus presque trois ans plus
tard maintenance et c'est toujours un
débat discussion entre vous c'est
toujours une erreur de sa part c'est
qu'ils sont encombrantes et nous en
avons beaucoup parlé dans les jours qui
ont suivi
sur le coup j'ai très mal vécu parce que
nous venions de faire une campagne où
nous avions des surtout pas sarkozy
surtout pas hollande et moi j'étais
partisan de 10 le soir du premier tour
nous n'avons pas été malheureusement
retenu
le monde est sens
livre vote liberté de vote aux électeurs
avant l'heure ça vous preniez une sorte
de mini avant l'heure c'était mon point
de vue et si on avait dit que ni les uns
ni les autres et que nous venions de
conduire 15 ans vraiment de combat pour
montrer que nous avions suffisamment
d'indépendance et de fax pour constituer
une grande force centrale autour de nous
et là des règlements à titre personnel
mais je sentais pendant toute la journée
je le décris cela il appelle à voter
françois le contraire on a parlé alors
cet épisode est connu maintenant ce
n'est pas ça qui a créé ce centre
françois bayrou les mois face au vaio et
il est maire depuis devenu maire de pau
ce qui est exceptionnel enfin dans une
carrière et il y est très attaché la
seule question qui se pose à lui et qui
peut se poser à lui c'est de savoir
s'est beaucoup engagée auprès des palois
s'il peut ou pas un jour juillet
l'elysée
d'autant que pour l'instant il soutient
je veux bien entendu ce matin le juge
alain juppé je suis donc ça va se passer
je vous vois déjà qui vont quand qui me
va ça fait partie des sujets dans nos
parlements l'avenir mais une amitié de
40 ans en politique il n'y a pas
l'équivalent deux hommes qui sans jamais
dépasser 30 ans il part et vous savez on
ne sait que faire un talent et il ya eu
des débats nous avons des débats vous
venez d'en citer 1 j1 a certainement
d'autres
est ce que c'est normal qui n'est pas de
chroniqueurs centriste à la
présidentielle ça peut être une question
c'est parce qu'on peut très bien en
parler enfin ça vaio et moi comme nous
l'avons fait dans le passé jean la selle
on est obligé de se quitter
là dessus avec vous tout finit en
chansons votre livre aussi au moment de
prendre congé je vous lis à la rencontre
des français
je voulais autre chose à l'escale
nautique tu ne verras l'allemand est oui
et ça intéresse aussi ceux qui passent
une super gestionnaire je ne me vois pas
là
voilà je ne projette pas je me réjouis
de la vente de 26 rafale six mois parce
que là vous internatinaux avoir de quoi
dire et on le vend aux égyptiens dans un
contexte qui est quand même pour le
moins incertaine faut pas oublier car
ils ont failli y aller il en fallait
tout changer de cap
moi j'ai simplement une question est-ce
que par malheur un jour séraphin
interrogations soldats et est-ce qu'on
n'aura pas à gérer la pénible situation
que n'a géré le président allende avec
les deux cuirassés way commandé par la
russie que nous pouvons vous l'auriez
vous n'auriez pas fait il ya le travail
à l'hermine 600 salariés
mais il ya aussi une question
essentielle pour une région qui vit de
la vente d'armes
j'espère que nous aurons ce débat parce
que c'est l'absence de débat de ce type
qui font grimper entre autres le front
national il faut aller au bout des
choses s'cusez moi peut-être c'est pas
trés trés
politiquement adaptée à la situation
mais moi en tout cas vous avez c'est
l'emploi ou les tic faut choisir
oui d'ailleurs je le dis un peu avant ce
mot nous à lire j'ai dit combien de
temps allons-nous premier but à van des
armes à ceux qui nous tirent dessus
parce que pour moi ce n'est pas rien
excusez moi d'avoir insisté pour passer
même jean lassalle ont beau moment de
prendre congé la merveilleuse mélodies
de charles trenet mot revient à
l'oreille douce france et je propose que
vous êtes un chanteur émérite peut-être
vous nous le chantier douce france
l'artiste ne fait jamais de femme juste
douze 12 on vous l'avez jamais fait
celle-là je la chanterais de ce france
cher pays de mon enfance tout le monde
connaît bercé le temps de l'insouciance
société garder dans mon coeur mon
village au clocher au maison sage ou les
enfants de mon âge hommes partager mon
bonheur
oui je t'aime et je te donne ce poème ou
je t'aime dans la joie ou la douleur
merci beaucoup il ajoute un petit
commentaire
oui parce que j'ai trouvé aussi des yeux
un peu d'espoir ils ne savent pas dans
quel horizon ni dans quel futur
ils vont le retrouver on va c'est ce
message d'espoir merci beaucoup jean
macé remercie et je personnes des sports
merci voilà mai
on se quitte à très bientôt ensuite au
sud ouest